ellen y comenzó una nueva vida en parís
pero hoy sólo piense en etiopía la
violencia está haciendo estragos en la
región de tigre donde nació y las
comunicaciones están cortadas lo que le
impide comunicarse con sus seres
queridos
chema mi mamá ella es mi madre no está
sola mis sobrinas viven también allí y
él nos pidió que escondiéramos sus
rostros por miedo a represalias a pesar
del acuerdo entre naciones unidas y el
gobierno etíope la ayuda no llega a los
necesitados las ong se están presionando
para un acceso seguro a tigre
no hay bancos abiertos todo está cerrado
nada puede entrar entonces que están
comiendo están vivos les pasó algo
durante los ataques aéreos no he dormido
nada durante un mes me despierto y trató
de llamar aunque sé que los teléfonos
allí no funcionan
desesperada por encontrar respuestas de
lenny y mira las redes sociales son la
televisión etíope salen pocas imágenes
de tigre aquí en el canal estatal
muestran a las tropas federales en la
capital regional de mikel mientras el
gobierno reclama la victoria contra lo
que llama un grupo criminal
los intensos combates entre ambos bandos
llevaron a decenas de miles de civiles a
huir de sus hogares
la comunidad de tigre en parís habla de
un desastre humanitario
mira lo que está pasando cientos de
miles de personas están aterrorizadas
por esta guerra por todo lo que están
sufriendo hoy en día estos manifestantes
acusan a los poderes vecinos de trabajar
mano a mano con el gobierno durante la
ofensiva el primer ministro había hamed
galardonado con el premio nobel de la
paz ha prometido aplastar a los rebeldes
para preservar la unidad nacional de
etiopía un país compuesto por más de 80
grupos étnicos